who makes the best tablet in 2023 is it
Samsung with a new tab S9 Ultra or is it
apple with the M2 iPad Pro well today
we're going to compare everything that
you don't see online including the
speakers the displays the performance
their keyboard accessories and much more
looking at the specs side by side the
price tag is identical if both of these
have 256 gigs of storage but the Samsung
the base model comes with that now the
interesting thing is that we also have a
micro SD card slot built in so you don't
have to spend a ton more money to
upgrade your storage like you do with
the iPad and holding this thing in my
hands it feels massive with its over 14
inch display and the iPad which did feel
big before well it feels kind of small
now the weird thing is even though the
Samsung is so big it is just slightly
heavier but holding it it actually feels
lighter because of its larger size and
its thinner design now what's also crazy
is that this song is waterproof it's
ip68 rated so you can have it in one and
a half meters for 30 minutes including
that S Pen which you cannot do with the
iPad and the S Pen is also included for
free in the Box instead of having to
spend 129 dollars so that saves you
money and not only does it magnetically
attach right here on the back like it
did previously but it can also attach at
the top now the iPad's magnets that hold
the pencil are quite a bit stronger and
I also prefer having Face ID built into
the bezel compared to the fingerprint
scanner on the Samsung even though it
has a notch built into the display which
the iPad doesn't have now both of them
have USB type-c ports but the iPad has
Thunderbolt built in which is nice and
they both have quad speaker systems
speaking of speakers let's go ahead and
compare them
Hallelujah
[Music]
let me know your guys thoughts in the
comments section to me the iPad sounds a
lot better the Samsung might be louder
it's focused more on the highs but the
iPad has richer mids and definitely
deeper bass so I would give the iPad the
win now with that when you're watching
videos the Sam Samsung's image is so
much larger not just because of the
display but because of the aspect ratio
you guys see that difference now this
video right here is an HDR video and the
Samsung has a Super AMOLED 2x display
which means as extra brightness and I am
seeing more brightness on this HDR video
than on the iPad even though the iPad's
rated at 1600 nits Peak compared to
about a thousand on this Samsung now
OLED should have perfectly black uh
darks but because the iPad has better
anti-reflectivity Coatings it actually
looks darker with its mainly LED display
now the resolution and sharpness is
almost identical between both of these
tablets but looking at both of these I
would have to give the win to the
Samsung because of the extra size and
the aspect ratio being better for video
the one limitation you do have with OLED
is four full White Pages the brightness
does get knocked down so if you're using
it in a bright room or outside the iPad
is going to take the win and it doesn't
have any of the flickering issues that
some people are sensitive with now as
far as the screen's performance with
their pens I'm actually surprised by how
well this S Pen works now I do see some
lag if I'm moving quickly whereas on the
iPad I see no lag at all both of them
have functions whereas the S Pen has a
button the apple pencil you could tap
but there is something to be said about
getting this included in the Box for
free instead of having to spend 130
dollars and now let's talk about the
cases shockingly both of these are 350
dollars that is a lot of money to spend
but which one is better now you guys
already know we really like the magic
keyboard case because even though it is
expensive you get the floating iPad add
up here and you get a really nice track
pad that is not a standard diving board
design and you get an additional USB
type-c port where you connect it so you
could be charging your iPad and hooking
up another device to the iPad's
Thunderbolt Port now Samsung went with a
different layout kind of like the 10th
generation iPad where you have a split
design so on the back you have this
protection along with this flap that
opens where you can adjust your angle
nice thing is you can use the iPad with
just this back portion if you're
watching videos and you want to take up
less space which I really like you also
have this little flap with the spot for
the S Pen if you want to keep that safe
from getting lost and then when you want
the keyboard it will just magnetically
attach like that and it basically looks
like a laptop and the cool thing is
Samsung has its deck software and this
automatically pops up right here so I
can hit OK and start and then bam we
have a full laptop experience right here
with full on web browsers I just
absolutely love Dex we have talked about
it in detail before and it gives you the
best of both worlds now talking about
this bottom portion right here it is
nice and thick really rigid and the
keyboard also feels very very nice and
then with that the trackpad over here it
is a diving board design but it does
actually feel quite nice it is
responsive and there is a reason why
Samsung is charging 350 bucks for this
because it is really nice as well and I
would say other than not giving you an
additional USB type-c port if I had to
choose one winner between Apple's a
magic keyboard and the Samsung solution
I would choose the Samsung especially
because of the multitasking with decks
now as far as the cameras both of them
have a regular lens and an ultra wide in
the back the resolutions are just
slightly different but here's the
regular shot and then here is an ultra
wide shot you guys let me know in the
comments which one looks better the iPad
does have a lighter sensor for AR which
is really cool and then on the front the
Samsung actually has two cameras in that
little Notch now right now I'm just
looking at the default standard ones and
here is a picture you'll notice that the
Samsung's image looks a lot more
detailed and that is because the iPad
uses an ultra wide lens that it crops
compared to having dedicated lenses and
even comparing the iPad and Samsung and
Ultra wide the Samsung looks a lot more
crisp to me but you guys let me know
what you think now the other nice thing
about the Samsung is it's horizontal
front-facing camera camera orientation
that means that using the Samsung with
its keyboard or just holding it looks a
lot more natural like you're using a
laptop where your eyes are centered and
your face is centered compared to using
the iPad and right now I'm looking at
the same exact spot I'm sitting centered
but it looks like I'm looking off to the
side if I'm using the magic keyboard so
let me know which one looked better and
which one sounded better down in the
comments below and now let's get into
performance because this is where we can
have a big difference I'm going to start
out with the SSD speed test right here
let's go ahead and run this and take a
look at that difference right there as
far as write speeds we have 1100
compared to 915 after comparing base
models and for 256 gig on the iPad you
get 1400 but as far as the read speeds
we have
2680 compared to 1532 or 16 20. that is
a massive difference so even though the
iPad has Thunderbolt built in if you're
transferring files with even 256 gig
it's gonna be quite a bit slower because
we have that limitation that's just like
with the M2 MacBooks where apple is
using a single Lan chip instead of dual
and as far as the storage I also have to
mention that SD card that you can just
add in your own storage if you need more
space but for a cheap price so I would
call it a win for the Samsung now as far
as processors we have the Snapdragon 8
Gen 2 compared to the M2 Chip which is
crazy 8 gigs of RAM compared to 12 at
the base and let's go ahead and start
the CPU Benchmark as far as single core
performance the difference isn't huge
it's only 16
but in multi-core we have almost 10 000
on the iPad compared to 5708 83 and that
just shows you the power of the M2
processor being in this than iPad
compared to the best processor that
Samsung can get which still cannot
compete and now let's compare the
graphics performance using 3D Marks
Wildlife extremes unlimited mode and
look at that we have 41.4 FPS with the
iPad and 23 on the tab S9 Ultra so it's
not double the performance but it's
getting close there and this is why a
lot of people will spend a lot of money
on the iPad because even though using
both of these day-to-day they both are
going to perform great the iPad is going
to last a very long time both in terms
of the performance to be able to keep up
two three four years from now and with
the software updates where the Samsung
it's great for now maybe a little bit in
the future but then it starts to fall
behind as apps get better if you care
about that kind of a thing and now we
need to talk about battery life the
Samsung actually has a larger battery
inside but as far as real world usage
the iPad you'll get roughly eight hours
or so whereas a Samsung you'll get about
six and a half because of the less
efficient operating system
and because of some other things in the
way it's set up and of course you have
the larger display as well so the
battery life is going to be better and
of course if you're just doing Simple
web browsing with low brightness you'll
get better than that but that is real
world usability and it's also
interesting that the iPad doesn't come
with a charging adapter it's interesting
that Apple started this trend and then
now Samsung embraced it all the way up
to their twelve hundred dollar tablets
but of course you get the S Pen which is
probably a better value because a lot of
people have Chargers regardless so to
answer the original question who makes
the better tablet all around well after
doing all of these tests I have to say
it is very difficult I want to say that
it is the Samsung because I love the
keyboard I love Dex I love the
horizontal camera setup the fact that
you can add external storage into it
that is where I'm leaning but a lot of
people that use Android phones still go
for iPads because of the whole ecosystem
where you have tons of apps that are
optimized for it so even though the
multitasking is nowhere near as good you
have more limitations it's more
expensive overall it's still something
you can get and use for a long time so
maybe you guys have to help me out on
this if I had to choose one though
having something that has a large screen
that can be very useful I would say the
the Samsung because of that Dex mode if
that's what I was using all the time I
would like to have that and having that
larger display it's a little bit better
set up I just wish that they could give
us a better processor in a tablet like
this and have more apps that are
optimized for Android for tablets
compared to the iPad but you guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below go ahead and click that
Circle to subscribe and check out one of
those great videos right over there
that's been Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]